-Our first guest tonight is a
Tony- and Academy Award-winning
actress you know
from movies such as
"Shakespeare in Love,"
"Philomena,"
and the James Bond films.
She stars in critically
acclaimed "Belfast,"
which is in select theaters
and on demand now.
Let's take a look.
-It was a great wonder,
pictures when I was your age.
I used to think you could climb
right inside the screen
and visit all those
strange places you saw.
Like that one in that film.
What was that?
Uh, "Lost Horizons."
Did you ever see that?
-No.
What was the name
of the place, Granny?
-Shangri-La.
That's what they called it.
-Did you ever go there?
-There were no roads
to Shangri-La
from our part of Belfast.
-Please welcome to the show
Dame Judi Dench, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much for
being with us.
-Thank you, Seth.
It's lovely to meet you.
-Now, it is
very enjoyable for me
to introduce you as
Dame Judi Dench.
I'm wondering,
for you, personally,
do you enjoy that introduction?
Do you insist on being called
this in conversations?
-[ Laughs ] No.
No, I don't insist on it at all.
It's a curious thing to get
used to when you're made a dame.
Because a dame here --
You know, a dame in America
is much different
from what a dame is here.
-Yeah. So, this is a wonderful
film that takes place in Belfast
during the troubles.
And I'm wondering,
you, of course,
were living in the U.K.
at the time.
How familiar were you
with this era of Belfast
before doing the film?
-Well, very, very familiar,
because my
mother and father
both lived in Dublin.
And so I knew a great deal
about Irish history.
And I was very much aware
of this at the time.
We weren't in Ireland
at that time.
We'd moved across to York,
in England.
But we were very much
aware of it.
And Ken has caught
the kind of essence of it
so wonderfully, I think.
I hope he's pleased.
I think he is.
But, you know,
it reminded you of
that worrying
and terrifying time.
-So, you mentioned Ken.
That's Kenneth Branagh.
And this is
a film he directed.
It's based loosely on
his childhood.
And he directed you
in this film.
You've actually directed
him before onstage.
And I think I was reading
you've worked together 12 times,
which is amazing.
It must be so wonderful to have
a working relationship with
somebody as talented as he is.
-It is, indeed.
And we met
a long, long time ago.
Behaving rather badly, I think,
on television once,
and we were both sent out
of the studio.
And that kind of
sealed it straight away for us.
-What was your bad behavior
that got you sent out
of the studio?
-Yes, I'm afraid we --
It was a very --
It was Ibsen's "Ghosts"
we were doing.
People don't laugh much
in "Ghosts."
But in this, I'm afraid,
we fell apart.
For some reason, we completely
fell apart and went to pieces.
So they said,
"Mr. Branagh, Miss Dench,
you can leave the studio now,
the two of you."
So we did, and it kind of made
a bond between us.
For a very long time,
it's made a bond.
-I imagine you are
a wonderful person to direct.
How was Kenneth when you were
on the other side?
Did you enjoy directing him
as an actor?
-I loved it.
I don't enjoy directing much.
Because, you know,
a company of actors
kind of gang up against you
when you're directing,
and they all go to the pub
and don't tell you which pub
they're going to, you know,
because they don't want notes.
After hours, they don't want
notes and things.
And once when
they were on tour --
It was "Much Ado About Nothing,"
and they were on tour,
and I went to give them notes,
went down to see it.
And afterwards,
he'd left in his costume, Ken,
so he never got
the notes from me.
But it withstood that
all these years I've known him.
And so we've worked
together onstage
and he's directed films
that I've been in
and I've directed two plays
that he's been in,
and so it goes on.
Thank goodness.
I hope it goes on.
He asks -- When he asked
me about "Belfast,"
he said,
"It's to play my grandmother."
I said, "I'm not
nearly old enough
to play your grandmother."
But, of course, it was back in
the '70s, and now I was.
-Right.
Yeah, it was a flashback.
It works perfectly fine
that way.
You have a grandson
in real life,
one that you got to spend
a fair amount of time
with over
the last couple of years.
And it's quite lovely.
He -- Is it safe to say
that he taught you about TikTok?
-He did.
He came down to where I live,
and during the beginning
of the lockdown,
and he said, "I think we ought
to do a bit of TikTok."
And I have no -- I'm absolutely
hopeless at all those things.
I said, "I've no idea how."
He said, "Well, we'll do it.
We'll rehearse it.
And then we'll --
You know, I'll put it out."
And so we did it.
And I said,
"Shall we put it out?"
He said, "No, no, no, no,
not now.
He said, "More rehearsal."
So we rehearsed again.
And I said, "How about that?"
He said, "No, no, not nearly" --
He was a tyrant.
And then, in the end, he said,
"Okay, okay, we'll do it.
We'll put it out now."
I've never seen
the finished result, actually.
-I want to show
you the finished result.
And my favorite part about it,
especially hearing that story,
is how proud he is
of you at the end.
I believe there's a bit of
a fist pump.
Let's take a look.
-♪ Juice, sauce,
little bit of dressing ♪
♪ Ice, wrist,
little bit of flexing ♪
♪ Juice...♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, I'm very happy
that you haven't seen these,
because your grandson, Sam,
has also taken to doing
TikTok reviews of your films.
-Who? Me?
-And we're gonna show two. Yes.
Now, we're going to start --
This is a -- They're very fast.
-You would slow them down
a bit to me?
-Here's the first one for you,
Dame Judi.
This is his review of "Skyfall."
-"Skyfall" is up next.
This film, hands down,
is her best.
I love this film. 10 out of 10.
No words.
-Lovely.
But I don't want to
make everybody here
think they're all 10 out of 10s.
-Oh, dear.
-He reviewed
another film of yours,
one that I was not familiar with
and, based on the review,
I might not be
rushing out to see.
This is the film
"Run For Your Wife."
-"Run For Your Wife" is up next.
This film only came out on DVD,
and there's a reason why.
But my grandma played a cameo
as a homeless woman,
who smacks Danny Dyer over the
head quite early on in the film.
It's a 1 out of 10 at best.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
-Well...
-I'll take it up with him later.
-Yeah. Please do.
Please take it up.
And I think we can all agree,
it's time to go back
and rewatch "Skyfall."
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations on "Belfast."
It's a beautiful film.
And hopefully, next time,
you'll be here in person.
-Thank you,
Seth, very much, indeed.
Thank you.
-Dame Judi Dench, everybody.
"Belfast" is in select theaters
and on demand now.